la junta militar de guinea consolida su
dominio un día después de derrocar al
presidente alpha condé el comité
nacional de la agrupación y el
desarrollo grupo a cargo del golpe y
liderado por el coronel mamady don bulla
anunció que creará un gobierno de unidad
para la transición
tras disolver el ejecutivo y el
parlamento los golpistas ordenaron
reemplazar a todos los gobernadores por
comandantes regionales aunque dieron
marcha atrás en una medida y permitieron
la reapertura parcial de fronteras de
cdn verde a los la rpdc y el cn rd
anuncia la reapertura de las fronteras
aéreas y la reanudación de vuelos
humanitarios y comerciales únicamente e
iván y te unicom a quienes no pueden
abandonar el países son los miembros de
la administración conde a quienes se les
ordenó entregar documentos de viajes y
vehículos oficiales además debieron
asistir a una reunión con la junta
militar bajo amenaza de ser declarados
en rebelión si no se presentaban en las
calles los militares aumentaron los
controles sin embargo algunos ciudadanos
recibieron con agrado el golpe donde
nos encontrábamos en un estado salvaje
no había más seguridad y justicia en un
estado financiero confuso todos hacían
lo que querían y su financiación
así que pienso que la llegada de don
julián es una bendición para guinea
jurisdicción por allí de el golpe vuelve
a asumir a guinea en un gobierno militar
luego de una década de un ejecutivo
democráticamente electo pero con su
popularidad en baja el levantamiento
llegó en medio de un creciente
descontento contra el facón de el líder
de 83 años y presidente desde el 2010
fue reelecto para un tercer mandato
presidencial en octubre pasado eso fue
posible debido a una controvertida
reforma constitucional ampliamente
criticada por sus opositores
[Aplausos]